here's the question simple setup
complicated answer kind of okay so let's
just think about what precisely is and
then we'll go about tapping it okay
finally grant value all the modules his
head right how far that is away from the
origin if you know this about Z Zed is a
particular set of complex numbers such
that this awful mess is equal to two at
this distance okay now how do you go
about approaching such a question um I
will show you actually there are there
are two ways to approach it
both of them work fine I'm going to show
you the way I went about it first
because I do think it's like it's the
first strategy I will take it turns out
that that strategy doesn't end up being
very useful at least not very practical
in this case okay but I'm going to show
you another less because in other cases
where you have a less complicated
condition it works fine and it is a
superior way okay how do we do this well
Z is some complex I don't know its
distance or the origin
I wonder the biggest distance I can get
and this is what I know so clearly this
is my basis okay both of my methods are
going to use that as a starting point
because I don't know anything else about
this right so this tells me there's a
locus to finds then can move around Z as
a point right you can move around such
that it satisfies this locker's right
now I usually think of a lock as in
terms of the XS and the Y's okay so
therefore my first approach is to take
this guy and to resolve what's going on
okay let's have a shot let's see what
happens right
there is any compact online right so if
I let Z equal X plus i1 there's my real
in my imaginary part okay then I can
just evaluate this get all the Z's out
of the way and get this as an equation
in terms of X's and Y's that's not
complicated conceptually right so I
could say modulus of X plus iy is the
first said minus 4 or X plus iy
that's equal to two okay now this is
progress but it's not nearly enough to
actually sketch out what this thing is
okay I have a modulus here right so
that's a distance to a particular
complex number right
this whole awful mass is a single
complex number right in the same way
that you know I could say that's a
complex number and this is a complex
number
and if I put them all together I'll get
another complex number at the end I just
need to manipulate it a little bit okay
so these two parts here you can see
there's going to be a real part of a
here there will also be a real part in
here there's an imaginary part here and
it will also be an imaginary part in
there I need to tease them apart and get
them together right so to do that this I
need to realize the denominator here
right so I've got X plus iy still
hanging out there what do I multiply
this by in order to realize it it's a
the conjugate of Zed right which is X
minus iy so I've got four times X minus
I Y and what happens is on the bottom
here you get difference of squares but
because there's an I squared in there it
ends up being the sum of those two right
do you recognize that so that is equal
to 2 now having done that now I can see
there are the real parts and there are
the imaginary parts do you see them okay
so I want to gather them together
because then I can take the modules
right so I go modulus here's the first
bit of the real bit X over there minus
4x on x squared plus y squared that's
the real part okay all the part that
don't have the eyes in them and then I
say plus I times what what's left well
Clube is the wider variables then I've
got minus negative iy right so I've
already taken that I out those two
negatives are going to cancel with each
other so it looks to me like I get plus
4 y on x squared plus y squared
cause - okay are you with me so far what
I do I separate out real and imaginary
parts the whole point of doing that is
now I know where this context don't
breathe there's the real part
there's the imaginary part so the
definition of the modulus is the square
root of the real part squared OC
imaginary parts right now this this is
the point where I write it down write x
squared plus y squared squared right
plus y plus 4 y or x squared plus y
squared squared equals 2 ok now I look
at that and I think ok I think you're
gonna pack up and go home
now for what it's worth this is not
actually irredeemable right you can
actually work with this thing one of the
big clues to know how to work with this
thing like that it's not like completely
impossible use what is the definition
like algebraically how do we compute the
modulus was it what was it equal to
exactly it's the square root of x
squared plus y squared now there's a
whole lot of x squared plus y squared in
there right there are a whole bunch and
in fact if I kept going with this after
squaring things out you get even more of
them right so the modulus of Z appears
in this equation all time okay however
even though it does I look at that and I
say okay maybe I will try another
strategy I'm not going to abandon this
necessarily but it looks like it's
leading me down the garden path of tryna
shoes are more efficient I try to cut my
losses basically okay at this point I
know well this is going to be hard okay
and of course you don't know what this
graph looks like this is not a standard
form you recognized in fact I went ahead
and I crafted it it looks like that okay
now if you look really closely in fact
if I I'll find zoom in for you can see
it's symmetrical um this it looks like a
circle but yeah no it's not okay it's a
it's much more complicated than a circle
okay
in fact it's a kind of shape that we
call a cardioid but anyway that's you
don't have to worry about that okay the
point is the point is
I didn't be distressed that way sorry
let's change that back now we die it
doesn't quit on I want it to be a square
grid okay my point is I don't know how
to work analytically with that so
therefore I'm just going to put that to
the side and pause from okay now just
before I go this this is still useful to
me right remember this is the lockers
traced out by that that's where I
started from right so that's the set of
points that satisfy this
so actually what I want is what is the
furthest distance that any of those
points is from the origin that's why I'm
trying to find okay now my intuition I
don't really know this but my intuition
tells me but at this point at this point
looks like it's the farthest okay which
is obviously this is the same distance
yeah maybe in somewhere up here but I'm
guessing it's there like if it's
anything like a circle then it should be
I should get a tangent here which is
perpendicular I'm expecting it's the
longest distance I don't really know but
that's just what I'm guessing at okay so
now can I try something else right come
back to here this was our starting point
you don't know anything else so you must
go back there okay I didn't do anything
wrong key there was no like extra steps
that again that was as simple as I could
get that is the shape okay the question
is what else can I do with this thing to
work with it other than try and work out
what's going on with the locus okay and
the answer is come back to what the
definition of the modulus is okay do you
remember when you start talking about
the absolute value of x that's what you
start talking about it right we just say
oh it's just the positive version right
and I told you that kind of works but
it's a very feeble definition okay
partly why is because it doesn't it
doesn't generalize to complex numbers
anymore because you can't say it copies
numbers positive original okay a better
definition I said was it's the distance
from the origin which means it's the
square root of x squared right the x
squared will eliminate that positive
negative information and they're taking
a square root takes you back to just the
distance now the great thing about that
definition right is you can apply it
right here
just as easily
right the absolute value of Z minus 4 on
Z is the square root of the square of Z
minus 4 on debt that's the definition of
an absolute value right there the
modulus okay
that's equal to 2 like that's that's
just what that says ok but I've just
taken a different path versus this ok
I'm all in deads I bought that X's and
Y's I can deal with this I'm going to
square out both sides so I get rid of
the square root so this looks to me like
our minds will expand this while I'm at
it is N squared takeaway X plus 16 on Z
squared equals 4
are you happy with that I square both
sides and while I was that I extend that
square in the middle ok I can tie this
up this is not so complicated I am going
to subtract 4 from both sides gives me
this okay and then I want to solve this
thing
I don't solve it think I x is N squared
which is great because I actually know
the centigrade cop is 0 okay so I'm
going to go ahead to the 4 take away 12
x squared plus 16 equals 0 just dealing
with it as a regular old polynomial no
big deal ok I can solve this thing this
is a quadratic in Z squared right it's a
quadratic you don't scream like that Z
squared squared so therefore if I go to
the quadratic formula I can solve for Z
square ok I'm going to get minus B plus
or minus the square root of help me out
B squared take away 4ac
are you okay with me you follow so far
all on - ok this is 12 plus or minus the
square root of 80 all on 2 that's 12
plus or minus 4 root when 20 no hold on
then I'd like to I took out a factor
from yet 20 ok the reason why I'm taking
out two is just because I want to cancel
that 2 on the bottom
you came with I could have taken out
more but I don't need to that gives me 6
plus or minus root 20
what is this what is this this is Z
squared right
I don't want Ted squared I want mods ed
but thankfully mod Z is the square root
of Z squared right
so therefore mod Z equals the square
root of 6 plus or minus the square root
of 20 can hold on
what am I just established okay it's not
that big a deal it's okay I've got two
values XI right what do I want which
value did I want what the greatest value
right so therefore I don't really need
to worry about the negative case because
I know that's going to be smaller so
therefore the greatest value for mod Z
is going to be the square root of 6 plus
root 20 okay now does that make sense
does it work let me prove to you that
works okay
now what I'm going to do is remember I
am trying to work out distance from the
origin a distance from the origin so
therefore if I draw a circle that has
Center at the origin like all I need to
know is the alleged radius of this
circle and it should trace out for me
where the lockers should go right now
this is the radius of the circle that's
what I'm expecting
so therefore when I've got R squared on
the right hand side do great so all
that's right is 6 plus root 26 plus
square root 20
look like that's not the same thing as a
true circle no it's not it's the
greatest distance I can find which you
can see like I like that very
unfortunately yes
corresponds to his points but I just
thought it there now there's the answer
there's the answer that I wanted um I'm
always treated so whenever you have an
answer I just finished and I ignore it
I'm always curious like what was that
answer what was it and I'll show you
what was if I draw a different circles
still sent our origin but I say well
what was that other guy it was six minus
the square root of twenty there it is
oh right in there it's uh it's these
these are the closest distance you can
be these are the smallest value of
what's it it's pretty beautiful